you
hi everyone it's Jerry I'm on chest coms
tactics trainer and I'm going to do
another group of three puzzles and
simply share my thoughts along the way
oh okay well I'm not sure how I figured
this one out but I figured this for now
I haven't seen it before but ok I'm
pretty sure the first move is ripped to
a4 and my initial thought is the you
have to take the rook King b5 King a7
and then c6 and there's no way that this
pawn could be stopped
yeah that must be what the solution is
if we're doing something other than rook
a for the rook is able to just get
behind the pond so I mean you have to
stop the rook from getting behind the
pond so maybe that's I'm not sure that's
the first thought that ran through my
mind when I looked at this puzzle but
for some reason saw this takes King B 5
or K 7 and then this C 6 move and the
rook is officially shut down but yeah I
mean first and foremost if the rook is
allowed to get behind the pawn there's
no way that we're gonna have something
good in this puzzles so it must be
ripped a forum of one yes that's the
solution or okay for rook takes rook
king b5 okay seven if we push there well
there's a couple of things black could
do you can push with c6 give check and
then pick up the phone or even play - b7
wits check and then go to b8
you know it's okay for it's probably
some in-game study see six locks down
and everything and were able to push
through and yeah just push again and
it's solved okay that one wasn't so bad
if you didn't end up getting that one
yeah you just have to first recognize
can't allow that rook to get behind the
pawn so you have to do whatever it takes
to stop the rook from getting there even
giving up your rook in order to get King
b5 and then this quiet move move three
with c6
prevents the rook from getting the poem
all right let's try another where we are
playing as black and if we're not
careful Queen and g8 is mate we need to
act fast
don't have time for quiet stuff already
hmm
penis man trickiness okay we have some
checks let me just say that I was
looking at rook takes pawn check King
here and or excuse me not King here but
rook takes pawn King d1 where's our next
good check I don't see it it takes pawn
King d1 good follow up checks aren't
really there
also Knight takes pawn check King b1
there is no check from that position and
we would then have to start worrying
defending g8 well we do have and I'll
know that this is best yet but we have
the move Bishop f4 this is another check
to consider this f4 square is indirectly
defended by our knight who could play in
d3 taking advantage of this pin and then
we could win the Queen
how we doing materialize we're already
up a lot of material we're up to minor
pieces so if we have to give up two
minor pieces to get the Queen hey that's
fine for momentum just thinking is there
a way that there's some Bishop check and
then this pawn pushing through
dislodging our King somehow and we have
our knight here defending
you know white would have to give up a
lot of material for something like that
Bishop f4 let's just say Queen takes
Bishop Knight check King d2 Knight takes
Queen in order to make this Bishop g7
move work I would have to eliminate our
Knight Queen takes rook Bishop here it's
too much material that white is giving
up pawn push in the end we're at least
upper look so that's really not working
it must be Bishop f4 starting with the
fork and then following up with another
fork yeah I'm not seeing anything better
it's just this idea to scoop up the
Queen okay let's try just one more
important to just note that certain
initial checks don't allow for good
follow up checks rook takes pawn king d1
the follow up checks are non-existent
Knight takes a to King b1 the follow up
checks just not there to look for these
other moves forceful stuff of course
because of this maid in one threat this
is the other check to consider and it
works out back-to-back Forks alright
let's try one last one here playing is
black hmm okay well
King is really short on squares if we
played rook check than I has to block
tits the only legal move so much
to make it work where the king is on f7
controlling here and then and then what
hmm I don't know actually if we go here
to control this square it also gives up
a new square for the king in 87
okay this seems like a start this rook
is pretty much out of play yes it's
pinning our pawn to the king after the
knight is moved but okay I gotta play
rook a rook h4 Knight h5 I'm thinking of
a knight move at this point it was like
he should be doing something else at
that at that moment move - I'm
struggling to find an additional
candidate move move one candidate rock
h4 is the only one I'm coming up with
Knight h5 and what do we do there I mean
we could give a check on f7 but after
king g6 then the king is ready to take
here is there something we could do
where we land a fork Knight takes pawn
with check somehow and then win the rook
do you don't really see that happening
if we have enough time what we could do
is give Czech night h.5 king f7 if we
could do like four moves in a row king
f7 Knight g6 Knight f4 and then rook
takes Knight mate but that's a lot of
time and what I could do while we're
trying to organise that that kind of
stuff where we're piling up on the pin
tonight the rook can swing over here and
then be in a position to dislodge our
King so thinking it must be something
else
rook check Knight h5 and something other
than this I this idea of king f7 like g6
etcetera that is just coming at a
snail's pace
is it possible to give me if we don't
have the rook on the board we sack it
for the night somehow can our knight in
ponds alone control enough squares to
give mate I feel like I've seen this one
before
it's but hmm clearly not recalling what
the solution is not a hundred percent
that I've seen it before but it kind of
looks familiar
huh let's revisit this again rook h4 9
h5 the knight is pinned
is there any rush with rook here
I was thinking like king f7 first and
then maybe we have rook da to h8 but I
have a problem with that
if king f7 this this might not be a bad
idea to try for that king f7 and then
were threatening rook here and in there
and defense of h8 with the king let's
say King f7 and there's a nothing move
like a three rook da King h7 can then be
met with Knight g6 and we will be
getting to h8 my concern however is that
on king f7 there's rook c1 and if we
play rook d8 there's gonna be rook c7
check in where's our king going
Brook seemed a bit too disruptive I
guess it's at least a nice an attempt to
a different way to look at it like
seeing this rooks flexibility let's say
from d4 it can't play to h4 or it could
maybe even go to d8 and look at the h8 d
8 to h8 idea but this feels too slow
because of rook c1 king of 7 rook c1 and
that rook is going to be a great bother
very soon
when we have something there can you
have seven rooks see one not seen
hmm I don't know struggling here
rook h4 9 h 5 it's not helping me as
soon as the knight moves giving up g6
and then you have to worry about f6
what I'm not sure what more to try here
oh you idiot uh-huh
what oh my goodness unbelievable
why do you need your King on f7 in order
to get your rook to AJ what's wrong with
h7 what's wrong with h7 how about rook
d7 to h7 it's a main to puzzle you goof
- oh man so million - I can't stop this
rook d7 to h7 it's me oh my goodness
was I was I the only one who looked at
h44 forever I mean that's a really
tempting mo right I come on let me know
in the comments section I was I know I
was not the only one who thought about
rook to h4 but maybe I was helping
helping you out some when I was
referencing this rook da to h8 idea and
you're probably a bit frustrated that I
wasn't seeing hey what about rook d7 287
hmm I don't know I didn't come up with
that sooner but okay that's just a
flat-out mate into a quiet move to start
even though there was that checking the
very appealing checking move but after
the night block there isn't anything
good I didn't really see the timing just
wasn't there to exploit a pin or
anything like that okay a mate and 2/4
the final puzzle there as usual feel
free to share how you did with these
three let me know that I was not alone
for this last puzzle please in thinking
Rick h4 was the correct first move for
forever let me know in the comment
section below how you did with these
three and as usual I hope you got
something out of it that's all for now
take care bye
you